[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the question
how do you know if you should throw
something away or keep it because it has
some sort of sentimental value and I may
or may not well let's just say I may be
breaking out something of sentimental
value value value that aia cups or at
least my mother my mother kept I would
and I would say it may or may not let's
say may may be an artifact from our
friendship in first grade
what first grade first man who is
kidding I know what it is but yeah we're
gonna break that out and but you know
what else we're gonna break out we don't
even have to break it out because it has
broken out look at this link oh my gosh
I'm who does the release of our novel
the lost causes a bleak Creek is upon us
October 29th is when it comes out and if
you preorder it or have pre-ordered it
you'll be you'll be the first to get it
and read it and then share in the joy of
us crafting this story now when we're
require experiencing this story now when
we're recording this
we actually just received the final
version of the book in the mail and he's
in half we were very very excited about
was with a publisher asked us they were
like do you guys want to do cuz there's
like water on the cover do you want to
do like the water and kind of a sheen
gloss finish and then above the water
and like a matte finish and we were like
do we ever oh yes
2019 baby it's it's funny because that's
not what we said I mean that's what I
thought yeah yeah that's like you're
you're you're in marketing no I thought
and I'm very glad I thought that because
I had seen it on another book and so as
soon as there was lots of questions like
you and Steve you were like well I'm
here that look like this is coming
samples and I was like I've seen it and
it's gonna be awesome y'all can get your
samples if you want but it check it out
this is my point right my point is that
BAM anything that we
excited about we also like at the same
time there's this like yin and yang of
it that's like well before we actually
all get excited here along with red well
I want to see samples can you send us it
you know it's like yeah I'm sure we drew
everybody we work with I mean we're
we're very collaborative and we when we
get we love to get great ideas from
people but it's like but it's also like
prove it because you know that's why
they have things called proofs I live a
sample free lifestyle
I don't leave court I uh I know I only
eat samples as an appetizer you know
what I'm saying it's like you want a
free sample
yes not so I can figure out if I'm gonna
eat it so I can eat more of it sometimes
I bet where people get frustrated
working with us because we're like we
can't just be excited about an idea we
have to be like but also but now a proof
of concept but we aren't we aren't you
excited about but wait yeah now we're
fully excited we got the endorsements on
the back and we've got pictures of us
and on the inside we I mean I'm just so
excited when someone becomes real hold a
piece of our hearts
now as behind this book and if you've
already ordered one order one for a
friend if they're if they like to read
books or if they've never read a book
either way
they they're gonna love this book and on
an upcoming episode bleak Creek doc will
it be in the next episode Kiko which is
where we're gonna we're actually gonna
do more in depth explanation well we're
gonna explore the book by kind of
talking through some passages and you
know we're gonna get more into the book
as a whole podcast but not only should
you buy the book because we think it's a
great story that you will enjoy but you
can also enter your proof of purchase at
bleak recom through November 2nd to have
a chance to win coming out to LA
all-expense-paid trip with you and a
guest to come and be a part of our bleak
Creek barbecue bonanza we're gonna have
a North carolina-style pig-picking which
incidentally is featured in the first
chapter of the book we're gonna recreate
that right here in Los Angeles driving
in a mow my way this morning void where
prohibited I brought all right perfect
no purchase necessary full details at
the website I brought Jay
to work with me but the but the
circumstances with which his send her
over Jenna
Jade come here I'm talking about you
come here brought in my dougie but i'ma
tell you this morning give me a little
kiss a little makeout sesh as you can
see she's she's just as uh she's just as
happy or really hard to tell as usual
she's docile she's cool she calms she's
collected but her motor transport was
different this morning and my hand was
kind of forced you know this story but I
just wanted to bring you guys up to
speed Christie comes home this is this
is a little ways back or maybe I came
home from work and she's like well
listen something something happened I
gotta tell you about I got pulled over
I'm like oh gosh okay and then
immediately when Chrissy's like I got
pulled over I'm just thinking okay I I
can't don't react just just be chill man
it's probably all over your face though
just be chill it's like an internal
conflict like what what why should I
react like what is it about me that
makes me want to have like a lecture
Asst or the type of response I guess is
what it is it's like well you shoot a
show with shooters you're George show
girl and I'm like I just gotta be cool
be supportive and it's not a big no
matter what happened it's not a big deal
obviously she's fine
she's like it's actually kind of
embarrassing and I'm like oh okay now
I'm intrigued now I might have an air
biscuit story get a little happy as what
life is about and she's a she said you
know I dropped Lincoln and his friends
off at the mall or actually another so
another parent dropped him off at the
mall so it was one of our jobs to go
pick him up she was like so you know I
went I went to pick him up and I'm
driving there and I'm getting to the
mall
and it get pulled over got the blue
lights behind me and the cop comes up to
the window I rolled the window down Jade
sticks her head out and because she was
sitting in my lap and the officer says
ma'am I pulled you over because your
dogs in your lap don't don't go now show
of hands in our small group that's in
here how many of you knew that it was
illegal to have a dog in your lap while
you're driving that it was a pull over a
bull offense a ticket a bull offense
okay I didn't know three people didn't
know if you had to told me that it was a
law be like okay I guess that makes
sense but I would have just thought it
was something that wasn't on the books
yeah I mean and so Christie that was her
response but it is like a book I didn't
know he was like yeah this is a you know
this is not safe for you and you know
what it's also not safe for your dog I
guess if like if you're in some sort of
an axe airbag your ping pong in that dog
oh yeah especially yes no it's not cuz
cuz that cuz by that rationale you would
need to put your dog in a seatbelt all
the time which I don't think is the law
hmm but I think it's it's probably safe
because it's obviously the safest but if
your dog is in your lap that air bag
which can do damage to and even kill a
small child is gonna do worse to it I
mean Jade is just gonna boom which is
why sometimes there'll be a sign that
comes on in most modern cars that says
passenger airbag off turn off because
the way isn't enough right seat mm-hmm
so for kids they're right or if nobody's
there you don't need to waste an airbag
maybe that's also where they're thinking
I got to keep my keep my ear back for
later yeah it's probably not that's just
how I think is you can't repack an air
bag like a parachute I've tried Chris
who's like I didn't know and then he
goes back with her license and you know
there's a sweated out period and at this
point I was like and was we're linking
his friends in the car please tell me
they were in the car she was like no I
hadn't picked him up I was actually just
around the corner
from them being able to see this whole
thing take place which have been
glorious for Lincoln's friends to have
to witness his mom get a ticket because
there's a dog you know but I believe
that the reason that he believed her
that she didn't it that he believed that
she didn't know because it was the truth
well no because the dog was in her lap
when he rolled the window when she
rolled the window down right otherwise
she would have been like get into the
passenger seat right I played it
perfectly and she wasn't playing she was
just being honest ma'am do you know why
I pulled you over I don't know but you
should ask the dog she's driving she's
in charge here because that's the thing
he can't well he came back and he said
ma'am I'm not gonna you know I believe
you I'm not gonna give you a ticket so
he didn't give her a ticket picked up
Lincoln spared him the embarrassment of
course I'm not right now I hope all of
his friends are listening what up fam
Lincoln's dad in the house talking at
you you know I know how to connect with
the kids you just demonstrated that come
over to my house you can swim them the
pool you can hang out you can play music
as loud as you want it can have
profanity in it because Lincoln's dad
likes the hip hop he's lit can you
imagine being my son imagine it a second
right well you're getting a call from
spam risk yes ma'am he's famines calling
you to get a spam risk phone call what
if your name was spam risk that would
really suck I've noticed that my mam ran
please put me in your caller ID is
something different
here's the thing jade is in control I
mean let's let's be real when I'm
driving the car what and I'm seeing
other people with their poodles in their
lap and hanging out the driver window I
see it all the time
you know every other day I'm driving you
see some pool to hanging out a driver
window what in and I'm job
always judged him like that's stupid
you're putting me in danger putting
yourself in danger actually you're
putting your dog in danger didn't even
know that um but then you know what I've
been bringing jadam and driving around
she she loves me so much I just can't
deny her being in my lap she climbs on
over and she Nestle's down but then
after a while of that she started
perking up and like perching up on my
left thigh and looking out the window
and I became that guy and she started
doing it with Christie and it's
partially my fault hello so she's been
she's been driving in your writing in
your lap while you drive she's been
steering practically yeah she's like
perched up on my left thigh which like
my knees kind of up beside the steering
wheel she's like right beside steering
wheel and I'm like I became that guy did
so when Chrissy told me that I'm like
you know what I'm I know it's
embarrassing but I'm glad it happened
especially with you not getting a ticket
because this is a freaking wake up call
girl for both of us because I haven't
felt right about it I've just felt like
I shouldn't let my dog control me and
rationalize oh she's so scared over
there in your scene but you know the
reason that you're the system has
completely changed in the way that
you're about to tell everyone is because
your wife told the story while the
McLaughlin's were with you yeah we were
on a double date and the McLaughlin's
buy things the Neil's don't buy things
yeah so Kristi tells this story and
we're in the backseat and all of a
sudden like Jesse's on her phone I'm
like well that's I mean it's a little
rude I mean like we're kind of talking
to you guys why are you why are you on
your phone in the middle of conversation
I didn't say that I was just like before
I could say anything and I'm sorry for
not giving her the benefit of the doubt
she was like well I'm on Amazon right
now I'm buying one because Barbara runs
all around the car we're buying a
harness for the dog while they're in the
yeah I didn't say what one was in a seat
harness for the dog but yes Barbara has
been in my lap while I'm driving but
Barbara so got to be everywhere at all
times that she goes around the car and
then she usually ends up laying in the
passenger seat with me
but not with you Wow Wow while I'm
driving she's in the passenger seat but
it's still not safe because she could
fly all over the car in the event of a
wreck or whatever so Jessie bought a
booster and let's saw all the way home
I'm talking I'm asking her I was like
read me some reviews you know I don't
like to look on my phone in the car
and like helping her find the best one
and then we found it and then she's like
do you want me to get you one I'm like
no I I saw another one that like is
higher up that instead of being a
booster seat it hangs from the top and
since Jade's smaller this would allow
her to look out and I've I did run
across that ad so I might do that and
then she's like oh I found it I was like
what send me the link so then that later
that night I bought one and it came in
the mail and this morning like what 30
bucks or something or not they're not
pricey that's right and so this morning
was the first morning we had it took a
picture to send to Christie look at her
look at her perched up there in a box it
this this little carrier box it looks
like something like a basket you have on
the front of a car I mean a a bike if
you needed to transport ET some way now
can she just she secured to this she is
not secured she's hop out there's a well
if you look at this picture you can see
that pink thing down there's her harness
she's not wearing it but ultimately
she's gonna wear her harness and then it
attaches inside of this box but you see
how she's looking out she loves it
she loves to look out but she wine it
you know she didn't wine less she wanted
to be in your lab she her ears went down
a little bit at first but then once she
realized she could see everything she
wanted to see she was pretty happy which
made me happy the plan is to put the
harness on her and and then attach her
to it eventually but I wanted to do it
one step at a time to get her more
comfortable with it look at her she's
like I might just give her her own fake
steering wheel so she feels like she's
actually driving that my big excessive
yeah well Jesse got one for Barbara so
as soon as Barbara takes a ride in style
I'll uh I'll take a pic well I know
something you don't know
Jesse's already given us that booster
seat because she tested it out with
Barbara
and it was too small so now the other
one Jesse bought is now Trisha Kristi's
car okay y'all ain't got nothing well so
you back to the drawing board yes we got
to start over but yeah don't listen
don't rationalize having the dog in your
lap when you're driving listen I
understand how difficult it is but let's
not be stupid okay
I've been stupid and my well I'm not
gonna say my wife's been stupid let's
just say that would be you just know it
was you you did things in ignorance it's
okay it happens now you know now you're
adjusting okay we're going to answer
some of your questions
we like carrying on the conversation
keeping the conversation going with the
mythical beast and so we're gonna do
that again but first we want to let you
know that you can get a bunch of
wristbands and you can put them all on
one wrist if you want if you have a
small dog maybe it could be a collar no
muscle yeah no no muscle you don't want
to do that because that could be
dangerous
yeah these are the mythical wristbands
amongst other things they are available
at mythical dot store
we got t-shirts Oh mythical calm why
what is wrong with me see I I'm still
making I'm still do Haven in ignorance
here mythical dot-coms I mean it'll
redirect so technically not not wrong
yeah you can get all kinds of stuff to
make your life even more mythical and
now your pets life even more mythical we
don't have a harness or a booster seat
yet but we've got a collar
we got a leash we got we got bowls we
got a spill thing we got hoodies for
pets you should be in a hoodie Jade
we've got all kinds of things mythical
dot-com all right what um I know we're
gonna unearth this the thing that you
got from our first grade year
with a subsequent question but let's
let's start somewhere else here this
first question comes from Ray n should I
pursue my dream and take a program I
like in college knowing that in the
future it might not exist anymore oh as
a job or go to a more guaranteed option
that I dislike hoping that I'll take it
later
did she say that I'll like it later
College starts in a month and I don't
know what to do okay it's a little late
cuz I think college has started now we
were kind of sitting on this question
yes woops I don't know what decision you
did make she may be she's undeclared I
mean if you just started yeah you
definitely could still change even if
you've been in college a while and maybe
it'll be applicable for other people
because the reason we wanted to answer
this question is because we're actually
exploring this with our kids I mean
you've got a junior in high school even
closer to the point of decision I've got
a sophomore in high school and so I
think one of the things that I've done
as a parent is I try to think back to
what my life was like and the things
that were going through my mind and what
I was thinking about life short term
long term when I was their age and then
I'm like okay well what would I have
liked to have heard from my parents at
this stage and again it was a very
different time again the generations are
very different and I think that the
amount of sort of in this may ultimately
be to our kids detriment but a lot of
times the amount of input and level of
discussion that we have about all kinds
of life decisions I think tend to be
more involved in detail than it was with
our parents I think is a cultural thing
it's also an Internet age thing there's
so much information out there that I
think so much more gets to us as parents
that impacts our children and vice-versa
I know you know we there's a culture of
more conversation that we have with our
kids than I then I think our parents had
with us in that generation yeah because
the the nature of the decision that we
made and I think it was very similar
it was very very simply we both took
physics our senior year with mr. Bryant
and we yeah I didn't even do that well
in that class I mean it was an AP class
so what I ended up being an a whatever
it was but I think it was probably like
a C is what it technically was but
because it was like weighted by two
points it ended up being an A but I
didn't really understand it I had to go
to Michael jubie's house two for him to
help me do homework uh-huh yeah and but
because I liked mr. Bryant and I liked
the concepts that we were talking about
and the experiments that he would do in
class I was like I should be an engineer
and I was good at math it's but it was
that simple my recollection is that our
guidance counselor put that all together
for both of us are you good at math
you're good in science you should be you
should be in engineering I'm like my dad
has always been a fan of the Wolfpack
that's where you go to get an
engineering degree right stay but it
wasn't this like have you been
cultivating or even exploring Russian
what it what your passions are and what
it is that you're good at and what kind
of gets your motor running that wasn't
at all what the process was because if
we had have explored what got the motor
running we would have known that
well something creative well and we what
we were doing that maybe we were talking
about you know we were writing
screenplays we were we were talking
about being filmmakers and we've we've
over simplify your dad kind of exposed
in when we went back to Buies Creek for
the for the Bleak Creek documentary
series that we did well it was actually
so we did that kind of exists we didn't
interview at NC State what really
happened was we did an interview at NC
State that they put into the NC State
engineering magazine and we told the
greatly simplified story that we've told
many times which is we wanted to be
filmmakers we wanted to major in film
when I told my dad that he said well I'm
not paying for that and so I ended up
being in it going to engineering school
now when I talked to my and I truly
believed that that was the memory that
was how I remembered it now I talked to
my dad after our
what came out even though we've told the
story me many times he said now you know
I was kind of misrepresented and that
article that it that isn't what happened
and we didn't then explore exactly what
happened and maybe it was the 16 or 17
year old Rhett interpreting something
concluding something on behalf of my
father that he didn't actually say which
is I'm not too excited about that
particular aspiration why don't you do
something that makes more sense and it
could have done something that just
emanated from him without him actually
vocalizing that and now that I'm a
father
I very regularly recognized that I do
the same thing there's all kinds of
messages that I'm giving to my sons that
I'm not saying directly but suffice it
to say the message that I sort of
understood was that you need to do
something that makes some kind of sense
and that scared us away from the very
open-ended insecure not guaranteed
future that was filmmaking now
thankfully we've made our way back into
using a very security what is circuitous
path Hewitt ist's circuitous path to
being in a creative industry and no
longer doing engineering but if we could
go back and talk to those high school
juniors high school seniors who were
trying to figure out what they're gonna
do what would we say in terms of how you
make a decision in rands question there
wasn't made you it
it wasn't specified what the passion was
and then what the sensible option was
it's a false dichotomy in her question I
will say though because I it's should I
do something that one exists that one
exists anymore like you want to be a bus
driver or should I do something that is
there gonna be autonomous or should I do
something that's guaranteed that I
dislike and I'm not really saying that
that's the false dichotomy I'm saying
the false dichotomy is that you're
choosing between something that you like
and something that you dislike
I don't think it's that simple but yeah
you're also right that you don't you
can't predict what's going to what's
gonna be around and I mean you want jobs
are gonna be able to support yourself
you know well there's a you know the
nursing field is only it's funny I
always hear well the nursing field you
know there's always gonna be there's
lots of opportunity there it's like but
you better you better be into helping
people and getting getting your hands
dirty to help people if you want to go
into nursing I mean if you gotta you
have to find a way for ultimate
fulfillment to believe that your
passions can be engaged in what you're
doing a that's the challenge is well I
think the first challenge is really
understanding your passions something
that well I think we were starting to do
but then figuring out the way to then
find the intersection between that and
their being sensible components to your
action plan that's like okay I I can
support myself someday at in something
related to this field but I mean like
well I think you're actually looking for
I think you're looking for there's three
circles that come together right passion
and I think I read a book at one point
that outlined this but I read this book
too but you've got your passion and then
you've got this sort of the practical
like what opportunities do exist in the
real world and then you've got your
actual ability right because there are
some people who are very passionate
about something I want to be Bob Ross
but you can't grow an afro exactly you
know hang it up so you might be very
passionate about something but you are
actually not good enough at it you're
not proof so let's just go with another
P you've got passion you've got
practical and you've got proficiency I'm
just making this up and that's not what
the book said it all and I'm probably
wrong but I think you've got to have
some proficiency of this you you've got
to have some reason to believe that oh I
actually there's a reason that I believe
that I would be good at this and not
better than everyone else but just you
don't want to go into something that
you're just gonna
naturally be bad at like I wouldn't
there's a number of things that I
wouldn't go into like I'm go into like
hospice counseling as an example right
because when people are going through
really hard stuff I'm not the guy you
want in the room
you know I'm hopefully getting better
that as I get older but I don't have a
natural disposition for knowing what to
say when someone's having a hard time
and so but there's a lot of money in it
so you might want to think about you
know this is that thing it's probably
not a lot of money in it so I think you
got to think about your proficiency your
passion and then what are the practical
opportunities that you have and then you
know what you got to do you got to
develop a you know I really this is one
of those instances where I I really
found myself wishing that you that I
wouldn't have been blazing the trail
between the two of us that you you know
I got married a year before you which
meant I had a kid here before you like
that's how the plan works right Lily's a
year older than Locke I really wish that
you know that you guys could be the
guinea pig I mean there's lots of things
that like you get really engaged and
you're like thinking about the way
future and saying I gotta figure this
crap out and I'm like yeah man I'm
watching closely you're like talking
about when I like get a TV and then you
get the same TV yeah yeah it works
differently with children that's silver
television that we both had for years
right because we both went Circuit City
I was like yeah if you're gonna do all
that research I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna swoop in and get one too i benched
every episode of alias on DVD on that
television I was like it was it was
old-school tube television and then you
got rid of it which takes us to the
other question later but let's stay on
topic for now so you are in a mess of
answering this question yeah like Lily's
like she's living the essay he's taking
the SAT week or something she's tape
she's taking the versions of the SAT and
the a CT for practice the last two
weekends in a row she spent three hours
taking both tests you know I felt for us
like
you know what your Saturday is gonna be
three hours of taking the SAT and then
the next week the AC T and then figuring
out I mean we you know we're fortunate
enough to have the means to have
somebody that helps us navigate how you
go about this and it's not just like the
counselor at the school it's the people
who will help you take the practice
tests and all that stuff yeah and
there's such there's so much there's so
much rigmarole to go yeah and we don't
there's so much pressure this that oh my
god the session me where the system
works right now and how things rewarded
in the competitiveness and how hard it
is it
let's just not let's just set that aside
cuz that's like that could be a whole
podcast in and of itself is the way the
system works and how you have to
navigate the system hi but list if
you're true what am I telling Lily like
it gives my question yet is the question
right and what are you telling Locke I
lilies at a point where she's still
trying to figure out what you know what
is she most passionate about and it's
like I don't expect her to have an a
simple answer you know it's like
honestly I mean I don't I guess I
haven't told her this specifically but I
think my underlying thing and I may have
said this before is that it just seems
like it's it's a crapshoot you know it's
like you do your best especially if you
try to figure out you know apply as much
of what we've talked about with the peas
and then you just roll in a dice man
you're seeing what happens and then you
roll with it roll with the debt roll the
dice and then roll with the punches
she's like I'm really in a biology I
think I think I'd want to be going to
medical field and be a surgeon you know
she had the spinal fusion surgery had a
huge impact on her life that was a big
life experience that then I think it's
at least part of that and then enjoying
those classes so we're like yeah there's
and then we figure out what would be the
path and what are the things that she
could do now in order to position
herself to get there even things like
okay you can get involved in this club
at school which then leads to an
invitation
this thing over the summer that is by
invitation only that then when colleges
who you know if you if you want to do
the pre-med thing ultimately so you get
back to those details of the planning
but then she comes home the next day and
she's like I want to I'm really good at
pottery you know like that's a P that's
yeah it remade and pottery are both
piece right and that was really long is
this only requirement she's good and I
find you know she's engaging her passion
for piano she doesn't talk about piano
as much but it is a P but she comes home
and she's talking about making pottery
and like how much she enjoys it and you
may say well that's a good pastime hmm
don't you see what I'm doing here but is
it a passion and is it a per ear and how
practical is it is it something you
should pursue it's it's impossible to
figure out by the time she's got to go
to college and Patricia late I don't
think so you get all that you're
violating the rule and it's like do the
best you can and be willing to change at
any moment or okay not at any moment but
maybe at certain intervals like six
months down the road man okay I don't
know I I just try to remove the pressure
let me so much my thing in summary is
I'm just trying to help
Lily understand herself have as many
opportunities as she can and then
develop a plan but then remove pressure
I think is my main role at this point to
say you know what I look at me I look at
how I got to where I'm at it it's I I
can't make a prescription based on that
no well yes so I think that even more so
for them that will be the case right you
know as time has passed people that
change their careers are more likely to
change their careers even more
times over the span of their working
life than our parents were we're and
then our kids are probably gonna be even
more likely to change careers so the
fact that we took this crazy path to get
where we're at does really inform the
way that we think about this in a lot of
ways oh yeah I also think that me and
you as you know pioneering as people
might think that we have been we are and
we've we've discussed this before but
we're actually pretty reactive and we're
very practical and reactive and we find
ourselves in situations and we're like
oh there's an opportunity there's
there's some white space there let's in
and we can we can win at that game let's
go play that game and that's kind of
what we've done and it's kind of
indicates why we've done a bunch of
different things and the path that we've
taken and I do agree that you know
they're gonna go to college and even if
they end up majoring in something that
is the career path that they ultimately
choose they're not going to really use
any of the things that they learn very
little of it at least you know even
going to school for engineering and then
doing it in even with you you were doing
the the co-op program where you were
working and then going back and learning
you still learned your job on the job
you learned how to learn you grew up a
little bit in college but you didn't
learn like you're not learning the
skills the what I was getting at is that
the college education thing is really
just a step in the process and it isn't
again like you said it's you can't put
so much pressure on yourself
but I think the real thing that we're
trying to do is just position them for a
the most opportunity that they can have
right and just be like don't commit to
something because of one thing that
somebody says do you like really just
learn to understand what it is that you
enjoy and what you're good at and just
know that there's probably like a whole
category of jobs that might work for you
and that's the thing that I've been
talking with Locke about I'm like
so you know not what do you think you're
gonna do but what are you passionate
about like who do you think you are is
it working with an eye poll ask it that
way is it working with people is it
working with things is it working with
animals is it thinking about ideas is it
executing things is it a combination of
those things working with people dressed
as animals yes and I think that if you
can just ask yourself those questions
it'll naturally sort of push you in a
direction where there's a sort of a
field of jobs so you know and you know I
think sometimes it's like okay some
people are just like I'm super into
programming and like it's my passion
it's what I want to do now obviously
there's ample opportunity for that skill
you can get a job doing that so that
question is answered and also you kind
of know the different kinds of jobs that
are going to require that skill and if
that's the kind of thing that you're
into you kinda have a general path and
some things are a little bit less
obvious like pottery is a little less
obvious right now you like what are the
different opportunities you can do with
pottery well you can be a person who
makes pottery you could be a person who
teaches people to make pottery right and
that's kind of it now it doesn't mean
it's a bad idea but maybe there's other
things we don't know you just yeah and
you kind of have to know like okay well
or I'm gonna go into this this basically
what I'm really saying is that I like to
do things with my hands i like to do
physical things i know i'm not i don't
want to be sitting at a computer typing
i don't want to be doing a bunch of math
and processing a bunch of information
but i want to be bringing something to
life with my hands i want to be taking a
raw material and doing something
creative and artistic okay you kind of
pushing yourself in a certain direction
and then there'll be all kinds of fields
some practical more practical than
others that you can kind of then look at
and I that's all I'm trying to do with
Locke it's just don't get too worried
about how I mean I want you to do well
but I don't want you to be totally
freaking out and trying to get into some
Ivy League situation and let's just take
it easy enjoy life do your best but
learn who you are and then see how you
can direct that tour in a general
direction and then it'll start getting
pared down as the opportunities line up
you know and as you come to know your
passions be very attentive to that don't
check that at the door when you're then
going in to make these practical
decisions yeah it makes it more
difficult but the the alternative is
even an even more difficult life of of
frustration
rayann good luck with that vada asks
what color should I dye my hair next
done blue and purple so far and well I
see in her like profile image her hair
looks like red but I think that maybe
purple green that must be the purple
green mr. another primary color you
haven't done yet green green and white
ombre it's kind of like Slimer vomit
that unfolds over time let's go with
another one okay let's get to this when
Molly asks I'm working this is at Liv ik
underscore o6 - oh I can see that she
came to an event and got a picture with
us because her profile picture has us in
it that's right I'm working on an epic
purge of old stuff notes slash books
from college and grad school childhood
mementos etc etc how do I decide what to
keep and what to let go when I'm on the
items that all seems sentimentally
important but intellectually frivolous
hashtag ear biscuits okay first of all
girl you're speaking my language and you
talk about an epic purge I you know I
woke up this morning on Tuesdays and
Thursdays I try to take just an hour to
sit drink my coffee try to meditate a
little bit boy I'll talk about that
later I'm just it's not easy
and then last 15 minutes Christy comes
down and like you know we we're having
some moments where we have our call
he's nice like an old couple o couple of
moments together and I was like what's
you what does your day look like and
amongst other things she told me she was
like I need to give Katie a call and I
was like when you do you need to take
that mirror to her and she's like what's
wrong with you I'm glad somebody else is
asking that question
I'm telling and she was like she wasn't
mean about it she's like I think
something's wrong with you I was talking
about this big honking box in our garage
let's face it my garage that's how I
look at it I look at the garage is my
domain yes also the laundry room but hey
it's not a woman's job my domain we both
do laundry in there but for some reason
I consider it like mine and my goal and
I've I'm sure I've spoken about it many
times is to keep it clean and like I
I'll take a picture and then I'll spend
three hours purging stuff out of the
garage and then take out another picture
just to have a before-and-after to me
and I'll blink before and afters and
I'll flip back and forth between the two
of them just to make myself feel better
and I'll show it to people if they come
over well I'm glad you've never shown
that to me
Wow I'll show it to the people in the
video farm and I just flip back and
forth and it makes me feel good I got
this big box it has this mirror that
they sent us to and didn't want to
return one of them because we only
ordered one for some reason they said
keep it okay
so I mean it's like five foot by four
foot box five inches thick that's a bad
as a lot of real estate in my garage and
Katie's you know Chrissy told me two
months ago Katie wants this mirror don't
get rid of it yeah I get this so then
this morning so I think I'm calling
Katie and I'm like you should take that
mirror to her shot I didn't even say we
were getting together I just had a good
call I was like well tell it again tell
her to come pick it up it's like it
won't fit in her car and I'm like well
um I'll take it out of the box and then
she can just have the mirror because I
bet the mirror alone fit in the car it's
a big box it's too much Patti she's not
shipping it she's gonna tote it right
and at that point she said again she was
like what's what are you about are you
okay
that's not really what this conversation
was about right so I actually feel like
I'm I purged to a dysfunctional level
yet I'm also an archivist of things that
matter to me and I feel like so I feel
like I don't feel like I'm healthy but I
feel like maybe I can help
well you know there's a house where I'm
come the minimalism movement and what
what's that what's that what's her name
Marika Marie Kondo so every little shop
you go into in Los Angeles there's a
book by this woman she had a Netflix
thing that I did not watch have you
watched it no I understand and I
appreciate the approach and of course
all I know about it is that you're
supposed to hold something up and then
ask if it gives you joy and if it
doesn't you get rid of it but you say
thank you to it went before you give it
away I don't need to read the books I
think I got the main message right okay
now I got a little condescending in your
own butt well because my personal
opinion on minimalism is that I actually
I kind of like a lot of like you go into
the one of those houses and like
somebody has like put a bunch of stuff
on the wall mm-hmm
and there's like stuff everywhere now
not disorganized not hoarder stuff I'm
not a hoarder and I don't like I
actually don't have real hoarding
tendencies and I get anxiety when I see
things pile up even though my wife might
say well you haven't demonstrated that
at home you like Art Deco hoarder I
wouldn't say I'm I like TGI Fridays and
like what they've done in there because
that's just a corporate thing but you go
into somebody's house and they need a
straw straw back chairs hanging from the
wall there's there's just something
comforting about like man they just got
all this stuff in it they did it for a
reason even this right here like we've
got all these little things now this is
wallet Nick Nash something that Cassie
put together and then painted gray I've
never really even studied it there's
texture but it just yeah add something
whereas when I think about like a super
modern miminum
minimalist house that doesn't have any
place to sit and there's nothing on the
wall I I'm just like it feels cold and
sterile and so I feel like minimalism
minimalism can at least aesthetically
can leave at that place but I do
understand the whole idea about like if
you got something in your life that's
kind of just creating unnecessary
clutter and time and like it's a waste
of time and it's waste of your energy
and your focus then get rid of it and I
and I do feel good about the process of
getting rid of stuff but what is the
connection between that cuz assam you're
describing an aesthetic to i think what
what the question what's behind the
question is more of like kind of a more
of a storage more in the garage than the
than the living room mantelpiece type
sitch you by the way this is I you and
Jesse must be on the same page cuz I
would just I I think that does describe
how your house is decorated I know she
does a lot of work on that and it's
amazing like we there's so much stuff
but it's it it's all purposeful like
that hook you got a whole wall yeah you
got a frickin wall that it's a shelf
it's 30 foot tall there's no we designed
it together on it we can we design that
entire shelf together but I think we're
talking more in a storage capacity how
does what you see if you're getting rid
of stuff how do you know what to hold on
to I feel like this feels like a very
organic process to me like when I am
getting rid of something it's like I
don't okay for instance if I'm getting
rid of clothes well sometimes you've had
a shirt for so long that it feels like
it's passed into some sort of momento
quality oh I got a couple of those you
know what I'm saying and then I'm like
Math Olympiad sure it's light and I'm
ready talking about like a obviously
stuff that you have from childhood you
know and like okay I found a wax paper
dogs t-shirt that Trent had designed the
front of oh yeah oh and it was like oh
I'm gonna then I feel like first year
out of college well I found a t-shirt
that said Merle rules the world that we
had repainted spray-painted yeah you
know I'm saying like with stencil that
we wore to a concert I think I can't
remember but definitely not letting go
of that we wore that to school on twin
day okay well I've got it and we both
spray-painted Merle rules the world so
we could be wearing the same exact shirt
there you go see
I'm glad I told you because you
remembered
but I have it so fries you have it now
you're always surprised when I have
something cuz you think that I don't
hold all this stuff and I actually I do
I just don't do it in a I don't I don't
do it as much or as intensely you have a
place because my answer has to do with
place yeah like storage but most of the
stuff that is most of this stuff like
t-shirts and old documents so you can
really get it small and flat and so what
I found is that I just have a place in
my garage yeah I actually thought about
moving it and began to move all this to
my attic recently but then I was like in
the case of a wildfire coming through
our neighborhood and burning up our
house you can get that stuff out I think
well I think that the garage would
actually survive because it's below
ground and I think that this stuff would
just the house would top of the house
were burning it all this momento stuff
with so I don't have to take it all out
that's my theory at least so I have it
all there and it collapses down and as
long as it's not a big bulky thing I'll
get I will get rid of something that's
bulky but if it's something that can be
kind of folded up and put into a box and
then I can put a label on it and set it
somewhere in my garage and not to worry
about it
yeah that's exactly don't I don't go
through this process of like just this
bring me joy slight now I might want
this later listen Nick I can make it
yeah and get it out of the way let's
keep it I mean there's there's mementos
but then that there's there's things
like the thing that your mom found that
we need to look at here in a second I
that are irreplaceable I mean especially
if it's like creations or something
that's and if it if it's if it's
irreplaceable and and it takes you back
and also second criteria it can be
stored especially in like a reasonable
amount of space like I got a filing
cabinet and I've got a couple of boxes
I've got an area where like I'm willing
to devote this much storage space to
keeping stuff so that when I go through
it it's a journey back in time or if I'm
gonna write a book like when we wrote
the book of mythicality if you want to
write a book about yourself one day or
share stuff with your kids or grandkids
all that stuff you should keep and you
should be real controlled on how you
store it and just keep it within certain
pounds like physical bounds but stuff
that's like if you start getting any
things like well so-and-so gave me this
or I'm well first of all the easy stuff
like I might have a use for this one day
I think if it's been X number of months
if it's been a year and you haven't used
it I say get rid of it but if it's
something that's like some so-and-so
gave me this vaz it's not it's breakable
it's not easily storable but it does
have some sentimental value they've
passed away or whatever I think you keep
it if you can incorporate it into your
life it's gonna be in storage then I
don't think I agree I think you got it
either find a way to bring it into your
life if the order you get rid of it
perfect if it's a piece of furniture or
something like that the purpose of it is
to and to utilize it as a piece of
furniture or a piece of decor if you're
not gonna utilize it for that purpose
unless you just have tons of storage
room yeah I said get rid of that and
that that's a point of contention with
my wife because we do have some things
that we've received from people there's
like a lamp never keep anything out of
guilt there's a lamp that her parents
gave us that's a really nice lamp that
they gave it to us a long time ago and
it's very ornate and it doesn't go with
anything that we had yeah she's just
like we have to hold on to that I'm like
but it's I don't it just two parts and I
just I would get rid of that yeah yeah I
would Craigslist that get rid of it now
give me the story of this thing because
well this is a good example of something
that should have been kept your mom kept
it well I'm so glad she did my mom gave
me a bunch of stuff you know years ago
that was we had she had kept in my
closet in my in the in the house where I
grew up in my personal closet and she
gave it all to me and it was pictures
and it was school work and it was a lot
and some of that stuff made a good
amount of that made it into the book of
mythicality as well but then there was
an additional folder that I had somehow
separated from everything else and it
was in a closet that then Jesse recently
cleaned out and then she found a folder
that has multiple things in it but I'm
just only gonna focus on the one we can
get into the other later but
she found from first grade in Miss
Locklear's class which of course is the
class that we met in a Thanksgiving
recipe book and I'm gonna go ahead and
warn you that we all had to design our
own cover for this and again just keep
in mind I was six years old and it was
1984 so do with that what you will
it was a Thanksgiving book and so as you
can see I I put a Thanksgiving themed
picture on the front of it so on the
Left you've got a pilgrim and on the
right you've got a Native American with
his arms outstretched yep
he's much bigger his he's got a AG for a
head I don't have any explanation as to
any of the choices that I made and I'm
not going to defend them why is that the
the posture clearly unintentional
posture of the pilgrim and the end this
like the the snicker I was on his mouth
like he's snickering yeah I mean don't
read anything into it I know you want to
read things into it but don't because
there's nothing to be read into it but
what there is to be read inside of this
book link is that every single member of
Miss Locklear's class had to submit a
recipe that they would enjoy for
Thanksgiving and then she Xerox them and
put them in everybody's book so for
instance you know it's you know you got
David Rogers who incidentally made it
into the book of mythicality as well
he put Nana's turkey dressing on there
but let's see if you get two handwritten
maari's cameran did what was a stir boy
stur dressing for turkey Christy's aunt
makes that and I hate it
somebody did cornbread stuffing but they
didn't put their name on there loser I'm
young remember Anja no neither do I it's
a recipe from Scotland though Oh Rhett
mcLaughlin run the glove ran blue cheese
broccoli
this is classic I wish you would have
well yeah but when you first told me
about this you were like you you told me
the premise but you didn't tell me the
recipe and you were like you have to
guess what it was and now again this
wasn't
thoroughly like what is it it was like
what I mean I'd really like this of
course blue cheese is a strong thing and
it's like you love blue cheese now yeah
so it's like it it was very easily
guessable knowing you now but it was it
seemed very surprising cuz it's like a
danger you also like blue cheese on your
broccoli and it was also you know I'm
asking my mom I like mom I need a recipe
for this book and she and I and then she
tells me you know and so she must have
really liked I'm sure I chose that no I
did I specifically remember her blue
cheese broth I said I don't think she
makes it anymore they tell you how did
they take you tell them how to make the
prepare the broccoli and it's got
margarine cheese and margarine very 1984
and then sprinkle with what cracker
crumbs at the end oh yeah I got to get
that cracker crumb baby 325 for 20 to 25
minutes it serves six to eight which
means it serves four mug Loffler
alright so I'm in here right so if yours
is classic Rhett bleu cheese the
question is is mine classic me well yes
it is is the mean now the me then late
Neil chocolate peanut butter balls I
mean I don't know why I'm surprised but
it's strangely validating that like the
things that matter most about me haven't
changed I love peanut butter no I hate
to do this to you but I will say that
Adam Nicholson just did peanut butter
balls so he had actually he's the page
before me yeah yeah well cuz yeah I mean
it's a pure recipe and you had to add
chocolate of yours which is a little
off-brand might I add I like chocolate I
love chocolate and peanut butter
together but yeah he the other thing
that's a little bit off-brand makes it
150 balls is that's a lot of balls what
is that that I drew at the bottom it
looks like salt and pepper shakers I
feel like I'm surprised that our recipes
like they're pretty similar in their
presentation in like
you know I would have thought the mom
would be really difficult to read and
hard to follow and not well organized
but they're basically very similar like
we both our mom's wrote them and then we
just copy them no no but if you look at
these other recipes like we both made a
very specific choice and that no one
else made we put a line at the top we
put the recipe name at the top and then
we put a line and we put all the recipe
your ingredients on each side of the
line and then we put the instructions
below it like a cookbook we have very we
have similar formatting in steno but you
put a link Neil at the top and at the
bottom you wanted to make real sure that
everybody knew that this was your recipe
oh yeah that's all bran as well
150 bowels and then we drew it at the
bottom I don't know why I mean that's
doesn't like broccoli at all it looks
like a bunch of people on a boat a
sausage shaped like a piece of bread now
so to go back to the question from I
mean I'm very grateful that you have
this I this is evidence of like what
what our palates were I mean we make a
living someone could argue just by
eating I mean if we weren't able to eat
our careers may be over that's it that's
I hope that's not true but some people
might could argue that eating food is a
huge part of what we do and the success
of where we are now but without this
artifact I wouldn't have been able to
definitively tell you especially for you
because of blue cheese that there was
that there was something there all along
yeah you might want to told me you know
we only have a couple companies these
books you might what it told me but I it
would have been a doubt in my mind that
I like blue cheese yeah there woulda
been a little bit of doubt it's like no
no no at that age first grain you like
blue yeah I like that the first time
they ever let me taste it but there's no
doubt because there's the artifact cuz
your mom kept it now you're gonna keep
it in that place in your garage and
that's important so Molly to answer your
question I think that these things will
I don't think it's about looking at them
and asking if it brings you joy or even
saying thank you to it I just think that
you knowing your soul when you
you know and your soul if you need to
hold on to something
unless you're a hoarder and then you
think you got a hold on everything and
that's a problem you need to have
addressed but I'm just saying if you
don't have that problem if you faith if
you can practically find a way to store
it that's not an inconvenience to you or
the people you live with I say hold on
to it because you might need it
especially if it's got some sort of
sentimental value if there's no
sentimental value and then you're simply
asking the utilitarian question I might
need to use this at some point follow
links rule and if you haven't used it in
a year definitely get rid of it and if
you need a mirror like I got I got one
for you like it's I if you get it you'll
know I got the same one in my house
because I had two of them so hit me up
hashtag your biscuits if you want my
mirror actually don't yesterday I'm just
being facetious
do you wanna you wanna hate I've Katie's
gonna get it you want to hit this
question quickly no I think you're gonna
save this I want to save this question
it opens up too much in instead I'll
just give a wreck okay cuz it's time to
check baby check baby wreck two three
four
my recommendation it would have been
better to go over the last weeks but it
was your turn to give the recommendation
and that we have rolls here you know
without rules we descend into chaos
we alternate who gives the
recommendation now if I would have
mentioned it because this is a camping
related recommendation if I don't
mention it my story then you would have
had the ability to steal my
recommendation but I didn't mention it
because I wanted to protect it from
being stolen by you well I'm not ever
gonna steal you're right I would never
and you know what I would never do that
to you you're good I would like to
highly recommend a book called second
Mountain it's a mom I haven't started
reading it yet but Rhett was telling me
about it my recommendation on the heels
of last week's camping in VR
conversation was and is if you gotta go
camping by yourself a camping hammock
having gone camping a whole lot and then
got falling out of it like I said I was
like the kids are going they're excited
I really I really want this to pay off I
want to validate their decision to go
camping and I need a little something
extra this time it'll something to get
them more excited and so I bought a
camping hammock one of these can't
hammocks that you string up between two
trees and it's like very lightweight and
packable I'll recommend the Eno is the
brand II and oh let's see I wrote down
its its it'll hold two people it's
called a double nest you can get one
this is called the single nest just
holds one person this one.you holds up
to 400 pounds
did you sleep overnight at it no check
it out there the kids loved it they
could get in it's kind of like a swing
it was something to play in if you don't
find two trees that are far enough apart
like I drove the FJ over but far enough
from one tree and then I you got to buy
the straps too and I recommend buying
the straps that have like multiple
places that you can hook up carabiner
instead of one so for about a hundred
and ten bucks you can get the hammock
and the the two straps with multiple
carabiner locations I hooked it up to
the top of the FJ and a tree and like
they were swinging from that having a
grand old time man
I was I was validated and then you know
what and aesthetically this isn't
working Christy doesn't love it but out
there on the pergola I string that puppy
up and I've been laying I've been
swinging in a hammock back there in my
backyard oh my like I'm camping have you
taken a nap in it oh yeah it kind of
bends you up a little bit it all the
blood pools in your in your well you
know she read it I've read about these
because I was gonna get one for a
camping trip and for like a solo camping
trip and you're supposed to on some of
the designs in order to prevent that
from happening you're supposed to sleep
at an angle mm-hmm that prevents I don't
know if this happens with that design
sleep at an angle so that you're not
bending like that yeah that you're
straight yeah and the
we'll hold two people I was really in
Toronto and I get in it together at the
house and it's you know it's fun you can
you can read a book take your laptop out
there and watch some watch some stuff
but um yeah if you sit kind of sideways
that does help with that
and it's as it's getting cooler
I don't know how I don't know how it
it's really it has a real cooling effect
because it's so thin where you put your
sleeping bag so you would have to put
your sleeping bag in it and you will you
would still get cold you got to watch
yourself because you got nothing under
you yeah yeah so I don't know about
sleeping it overnight in a cold
environment but boy it just breathes new
life into your camping experience and so
I highly recommend getting yourself a
hammock you hang it up at home but if
you get yourself a hammock and you don't
use it for a year get rid of it
it's stuffable it gets down to be this
small okay put it with your other
lovable trinkets yeah well you know put
it in and put it in a put it up on a
shelf in your garage but with your
camping gear Mabel you use it again you
know a lot certain amount of space in
the garage for my camping gear I got
some Tupperware's associated with that
and you shove it in there until next
time may all your hammocks be in use in
all your trinkets be stored in a place
that won't burn up in a fire and your
passions engaged hash tag your biscuits
let us know if you agree or disagree or
if you can sprinkle some more light on
what we discussed today we would
appreciate well I'm glad that you salute
that you listen that's a relief to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]